हे एवरीवन दिस इज नितेश फाउंडर ऑफ डिफ्रॉक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी काफी टाइम बाद हम मिल
रहे हैं लेकिन एज प्रॉमिस मिड नवंबर में
एक सरप्राइज आपके लिए होगी वो सरप्राइज
लेकर आया हूं एक ग्रैंड अनाउंसमेंट के साथ
आप सबके पास हाजिर हूं मैं फिर से एंड इस
अनाउंसमेंट के बाद आपको बहुत बहुत ज्यादा
मजा आने वाला है क्योंकि आपके करियर के
लिए अनाउंसमेंट है आपके अपलिफ्टमेंट के
लिए अनाउंसमेंट है आपके अप स्किलिंग के
लिए ये अनाउंसमेंट है एंड उन स्टूडेंट्स
के ये अनाउंसमेंट है जो कॉस्टली कोर्सेस
एंड ट्रेनिंग को अफोर्ड नहीं कर पाते बट
क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग चाहते हैं क्वालिटी
कंटेंट क्वालिटी नॉलेज चाहते हैं सीखना
चाहते हैं साइबर सिक्योरिटी के फील्ड में
एज आई ऑलरेडी से कि हमारा जो मोटो है वो
है आइ दर फ्री और मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल एजुकेशन
का थ्रू डेफॉक्स एंड वो हम प्रोवाइड करते
रहेंगे आगे भी अभी भी हम कर रहे हैं
डेनिक्स पे बग बाउंट की सीरीज ऑलरेडी चल
रही है उसमें थोड़ा डिले हुआ है क्योंकि
कुछ ऑफलाइन सेटअप के काम में बिजी हो गया
था मैं जैसा कि मैं आपको ऑलरेडी बोल चुका
हूं बता चुका हूं कि डेनिक्स जो है
नेक्स्ट ईयर q1 क्वार्टर वन में आपकी
ऑफलाइन आने वाली है डेल्ली एनसीआर में
एग्जैक्ट डेट एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन सब कुछ ऑफिस
का लोकेशन सब मैं आपके साथ शेयर करूंगा बट
थोड़ा टाइम और लगेगा एंड देन यू विल गेट
टू नो द एग्जैक्ट एवरीथिंग तो उस काम में
थोड़ा बिजी चल रहा था तो डेनिक्स पे जो बग
बाउंट की सीरीज चल रही है उसकी
फ्रीक्वेंसी में थोड़ी सी डिले आ गई लेकिन
अब जो है वो सीरीज भी बहुत जल्द कंटिन्यू
होने वाली है एंड नेक्स्ट सेशन कल ही होने
वाली है तो उसके लिए वो जो सीरीज है आपकी
जो बग बाउंट की वो कंटिन्यू चलती रहेगी वो
स्टॉप नहीं होगी एंड इसके साथ ही एक जो
अनाउंसमेंट है जो एक ह्यूज ग्रैंड
अनाउंसमेंट है वो ये कि हम एक हमारी
नेक्स्ट फ्री लाइव बट विद क्वालिटी
ट्रेनिंग लेकर आ रहे हैं जिसका नाम होने
वाला है डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल ये एक
ट्रेनिंग कम सर्टिफिकेशन फ्री ट्रेनिंग है
यानी कि इस ट्रेनिंग को आप बिल्कुल फ्री
ऑफ कॉस्ट में कर सकते हैं यानी कि अगर हम
इस ट्रेनिंग को पेड बेसिस पे भी लेकर आ
सकते थे अगर हम चाहते हैं एंड फिर इसकी
सर्टिफिकेशन आपको प्रोवाइड कराते बट यहां
पे ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट फ्री आपको प्रोवाइड
कराने वाले हैं डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
यानी डि फ्रॉक्स सर्टिफाइड जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल प्रैक्टिकल अब इस
ट्रेनिंग को करने के बाद आप जो इंटरनेशनल
काफी सारे सर्टिफिकेशन प्रैक्टिकल
सर्टिफिकेशंस हैं ईज पीटी ओएसपी ऐसे
सिलेबस को हमने कवर करने की कोशिश करी है
इस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग के अंदर में एंड
उनका बहुत सारा पार्ट हमने इसमें इंक्लूड
करा है डिटेल सिलेबस मैं आपको अभी स्क्रीन
पे चल के बताऊंगा दिखाऊंगा क्या-क्या
सिलेबस है बट जो सिलेबस हमने इसमें कवर
करी है सिर्फ उतनी कंटेंट ही नहीं आएंगी
इसके अंदर और भी बहुत सारे कंटेंट्स आगे
फ्यूचर में हम एड अप करेंगे बट अभी जो
सिलेबस आपको प्रोवाइड किया जाएगा दिखाया
जाएगा वो ऑटोमेटिक मतलब अपने आप में बहुत
ह्यूज सिलेबस है यानी कि सिलेबस के अंदर
बहुत सारी चीजें ऑलरेडी पड़ी पड़ी है एंड
आपको देख के बहुत ज्यादा मजा आने वाला है
इस सिलेबस को अब डीसी जीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
इस सीरीज को करने के लिए थोड़े प्री
रिक्विजिट्स हैं वो क्या है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं आपके पास एक लैपटॉप तो होना ही
चाहिए आपके पास एक अच्छी इंटरनेट कनेक्शन
होनी चाहिए पैशन होना चाहिए बहुत सारा टू
लर्न साइबर सिक्योरिटी टू कम इनसाइड साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन एंड आप हमारे डीसी
जेएसपी जो हमारी कोर्स है जो कि एक प्री
रिकॉर्डेड कोर्स है डीसी जीएसपी जिसे आप
हमारे डेनिक्स अकेडमी ए एप पे भी जाके
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं वो कोर्स अगर आपने
किया हुआ है तो आपके लिए और भी ज्यादा इजी
होगा क्योंकि ये जो प्रैक्टिकल कोर्स है
कंप्लीट तो आपको यहां पे प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेट ज्यादा मिलेंगे बट थरी वाला
पार्ट अगर आप कवर करना चाहते हैं डिटेल इन
डेप्थ सीखना चाहते हैं तो आप डीसी जेएसपी
जो हमारी कोर्स है जिसका लिंक आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी मिल जाएगा या आप
डेनिक्स
academy-raviryala एक अच्छे खासे एडवांस
लेवल पर लेकर जाया जाएगा इस पर्टिकुलर
फ्री लाइव ट्रेनिंग के रूप में अब यहां पे
यह जो ट्रेनिंग है स्टार्ट हो रही है 10थ
ऑफ नवंबर से जी हां 10th ऑफ नवंबर को पहली
क्लास इसकी होने वाली है एंड वो 7 पीएम पे
होगी आपके डेफॉक्स अकेडमी
youtube1 क्लासेस कब होंगी नेक्स्ट
कौन-कौन से रिसोर्सेस हम आपसे शेयर करेंगे
क्या क्या अपडेट्स इन सारे अपडेट्स के लिए
आपको हमारे
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगा
डेनिक्स साइबर वरियर के नाम से आपको चैनल
मिल जाएगा डेनिक्स साइबर वरियर उसको आप
जवाइन कर लीजिएगा फॉलो कर लीजिएगा बिल्कुल
फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है उस
whatsapp.app चैनल को जवाइन करना बिल्कुल
मत भूलिए डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक मिल
जाएगी नाउ डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल
ट्रेनिंग का भी प्राइम मोटो है कि
क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग प्रोवाइड करना उन
स्टूडेंट्स को जो महंगी या कॉस्टली
कोर्सेस ट्रेनिंग को अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते
हैं इंटरनेट पे बहुत सारी फ्री जो है
क्लासेस या ट्रेनिंग या कोर्सेस अवेलेबल
होते हैं बट उनमें जब मैं उनको देखता हूं
तो उनमें क्वालिटी की कमी होती है क्योंकि
वो फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट होता है और उनका मेन
प्राइमरी मोटिव होता है कि एक पेड
ट्रेनिंग की तरफ लेकर जाना उस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग के तरफ से तो इस वजह से उसमें
कंटेंट बस उसी हिसाब से होता है मिलाजुला
कंटेंट आपको मिलेगा एवरेज कंटेंट मिलेगा
उस बैरियर को हम ब्रेक डाउन करना चाहते
हैं हम चाहते हैं कि आपको जो यहां कंटेंट
मिल रहा है वो फ्री तो हो साथ में
क्वालिटी कंटेंट हो आपको ऐसा ना मिले कि
फ्री के नाम पे कुछ भी दे दिया है आपको
क्वालिटी चीजें मिले तो वो हम डीसी जसपी
प्रैक्टिकल में भी मेंटेन करने वाले हैं
एंड आप सबके लिए लेकर आ रहे हैं इस
ट्रेनिंग से रिलेटेड एक खास बात यह है कि
हम इस ट्रेनिंग को कंप्लीट करने के बाद
इसका एक सर्टिफिकेशन भी लॉन्च करेंगे डीसी
जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल का सर्टिफिकेशन तो जो
भी स्टूडेंट्स या जो भी ऐसे लोग होंगे जो
सर्टिफिकेशन भी लेना चाहेंगे वो
सर्टिफिकेशन एग्जाम अटेंप्ट करके वो
सर्टिफिकेशन ले सकते हैं उस एग्जाम को को
अटेंप्ट करने के लिए एंड उस एग्जाम को
क्रैक करने के लिए आपका जो सिलेबस होगा वो
यही पूरी सीरीज होगी यानी कि ये एक प्रॉपर
ट्रेनिंग है ऐसा नहीं है कि कुछ भी आपको
प्रोवाइड किया जा रहा है एक प्रॉपर
ट्रेनिंग एक प्रॉपर स्ट्रक्चर्ड वे में
आपको फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट डिलीवर किया जाएगा इस
पर्टिकुलर डीसीजीए पी प्रैक्टिकल के थ्रू
ठीक है तो आपको उसकी भी अनाउंसमेंट उसकी
डिटेल्स भी जब ये प्रैक्टिकल सीरीज खत्म
होगी जब आपकी ट्रेनिंग खत्म होगी तो वो भी
प्रोवाइड कर दी जाएगी बट एक बात हमेशा
ध्यान में रखना है कि ये जो पूरी सीरीज या
जो भी ये फ्री कोर्सेस आ रहे हैं ये पूरी
क्वालिटी के साथ आपको मिलते हैं क्योंकि
हमारे पास बहुत सारे ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स आते
हैं जो हमसे बोलते हैं कि क्या मुझे कुछ
डिस्काउंट मिल सकता है कोर्स पे या क्या
मैं फ्री में मिल सकता है कुछ लोगों को तो
हम प्रोवाइड कर देते हैं बट बहुत सारे
लोगों को शायद प्रोवाइड हम ना कर पाए
क्योंकि एज अ कंपनी पर्सपेक्टिव जब देखें
तो कंपनी के अंदर और भी लोग होते हैं
जिनका डिसीजन होता है प्रॉफिट शेयरिंग
जिनके साथ होती है तो हो सकता है वो अग्री
ना करें जितना हम कर सकते हैं उतना हम
करेंगे एंड इसलिए हमने डि फ्रक्स अकेडमी
पे फ्री सीरीज चलानी स्टार्ट करी कि
एटलीस्ट हम इसके थ्रू तो आपको फ्री एंड
क्वालिटी कंटेंट प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं अगर
हम वहां पे आपको डिस्काउंट ज्यादा नहीं दे
पा रहे हैं या फ्री में नहीं दे पा रहे
हैं तो तो इस बात को आई होप कि आप सब समझ
रहे होंगे एंड आप सब हमारे साथ रहेंगे आप
इस वीडियो को इस अनाउंसमेंट को अपने
दोस्तों के बीच भी शेयर करेंगे ताकि उन तक
यह बात पहुंचे एंड वो भी इस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग से जुड़ पाए चलिए लैपटॉप स्क्रीन
पे आपको पूरी सिलेबस दिखाते हैं मैं आपको
डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल की पूरी सिलेबस जो
है वो दिखाता हूं एंड आपको सारी चीजें
बताता हूं इस पर्टिकुलर कोर्स में इस
पर्टिकुलर फ्री लाइव ट्रेनिंग में हम
क्या-क्या चीजें सीखने वाले हैं वैसे यह
सिलेबस अपने आप में ह्यूज है बट ये
क्योंकि डायनामिक कोर्स है तो इसमें हम और
भी टॉपिक्स फ्यूचर में ऐड करेंगे इसका नाम
है डीसी जेएसपी डिफक सर्टिफाइड जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल प्रैक्टिकल डीसी
जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल वर्जन वन एंड सिलेबस के
कंटेंट शुरू होते हैं यहां से हाउ टू सेट
अप पेन टेस्टिंग लैब्स इसके साथ हम कवर
करेंगे फंडामेंटल ऑफ लिनिक्स फंडामेंटल ऑफ
विंडोज साथ में हम ओन कवर करेंगे बहुत
सारे ओन के टॉपिक्स यहां कवर करने वाले
हैं सीआई ट्राइट को देखने वाले हैं ओआई
मॉडल को हम कवर करने वाले हैं फुट
प्रिंटिंग एंड रिकॉन सेंस को हम देखेंगे
यहां डीप रिकॉर्न की मैं बात कर रहा हूं
नॉट जस्ट सिंपल रिकॉर्न तो डीप रिकॉर्न हम
देखने वाले हैं स्कैनिंग हम पूरी कवर
करेंगे न्यूमरेशन हम पूरी कवर करने वाले
हैं साथ में वल्नरेबल एनालिसिस को हम
इंडस्ट्री लेवल पे कवर करने वाले हैं
सिस्टम हैकिंग हमारी इसमें कवर होगी
हम बात करेंगे सोशल इंजीनियरिंग डिनायल ऑफ
सर्विस सेशन हाईजैकिंग इनको कवर करने वाले
हैं हैकिंग वेब सर्वर इनको हम करने वाले
हैं वेब एप्लीकेशन पन टेस्टिंग भी इस
सिलेबस का पार्ट है नाउ अब वेब एप्लीकेशन
पेन टेस्टिंग की सीरीज ऑलरेडी बग बाउंट
में चल ही रही है हमारी तो वहां पे आपको
ये सारे कवर्ड ऑलरेडी मिलेंगे जो रह गए
होंगे वो ऑलरेडी कवर हो जाएंगे तो ये
क्योंकि सिलेबस का पार्ट है इसलिए हमने
यहां पे मेंशन कर रखा है क्योंकि एज हमने
बताया कि डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल का एक
सर्टिफिकेशन हम लेकर आएंगे इस कोर्स के
कंप्लीट होने के बाद क्योंकि ये एक लंबा
कोर्स है तो इसमें हो सकता है चार से पाच
महीने लग जाए इसको पूरा कंप्लीट होने में
उसके बाद सर्टिफिकेशन हम लेके आएंगे तो उस
सर्टिफिकेशन एग्जाम को क्रैक करने के लिए
आपका सिलेबस यही होगा तो उसमें ये भी होगा
तो आप इसको बग बांटी के थ्रू ओबवियसली कवर
कर सकते हैं साथ में वायरलेस पेन टेस्टिंग
को हम देखने वाले हैं बहुत ही अच्छे से
अच्छे लेवल पे डीप में देन हम पाइवट यानी
कि लैटरल मूवमेंट मूविंग इनसाइड नेटवर्क
एंड क्रिप्टोग्राफी को भी कवर करने वाले
हैं अच्छे लेवल पे क्रिप्टोग्राफी आपकी
कवर होगी बहुत सारे टूल्स इसमें कवर्ड
होंगे जो यहां पे आपको दिखाए गए हैं साथ
में यहां पे कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन है यह जो ट्रेनिंग या लाइव
ट्रेनिंग फ्री कोर्स है आपकी ये किसी भी
स्टूडेंट के लिए है ऐसा कोई भी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है कि आपका कोई टेक
बैकग्राउंड या कुछ ऐसा स्टैंडर्ड होना
चाहिए नहीं आप किसी भी बैकग्राउंड से हैं
किसी भी टेक्निकल बैकग्राउंड से हैं चाहे
वो आप 12थ में हो 10थ में हो चाहे वो आप
नॉन टेक हो टेक हो आपके अंदर पैशन है
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में करियर बनाना है आपको
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में नॉलेज गेन करनी
स्किल्स गेन करना है देन दिस ट्रेनिंग इज
एब्सलूट फॉर यू बस
दैट्ची कंप्यूटर का तो अच्छा है बेसिक
इंटरनेट की जानकारी है तो अच्छी बात है
अगर आप टास्क करना जानते हैं तो यह बहुत अ
एक अच्छी प्रैक्टिस होगी क्योंकि इस
ट्रेनिंग के दौरान आपको अलग-अलग टास्क्स
दिए जाएंगे जिनको आपको परफॉर्म करना है
करना है और
है वो मोर देन 150 आवर्स का है मतलब समझ
सकते हो आप एक 150 घंटे से भी ज्यादा का
यह कोर्स है ठीक है एंड ये बहुत ही
अमेजिंग होने वाला है आप सबके लिए यकीन
मानिए इस कोर्स को करने के बाद आपको जो
नॉलेज और जो कॉन्फिडेंस मिलेगा वो डिफरेंट
लेवल का होगा और वो भी फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
दैट्ची डीसी जेएसपी जो एक थियोरेटिकल
कोर्स है थियोरेटिकल प्रैक्टिकल दोनों है
बेसिकली एथिकल हैकिंग की तो अगर आप यह
कोर्स कर चुके हैं तो वेल एंड गुड काफी
अच्छा है आपका बेस ऑलरेडी स्ट्रांग है बट
अगर आप चाहते हैं कि आपका एकदम बेस
स्ट्रांग हो एंड आपको एथिकल हैकिंग की
अच्छी नॉलेज हो तो आप डीसी जेएसपी के लिए
जा सकते हैं इसके साथ-साथ पैरेलल ये हमारी
2499 की प्री रिकॉर्डेड वीडियो कोर्स होती
है जिसको कि आप यहां से जाके इनरोल कर
सकते हैं . क साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी
कोर्स पेज पे यहां सारी डिटेल्स आप देख
सकते हैं एंड यहां से आप आके सिंपली यहां
पे नरोल नाउ पे क्लिक करके यहां पे इनरोल
कर सकते हैं यहां पे आप एनरोल नाउ पे
क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे गेट दिस कोर्स पे
क्लिक करेंगे यहां पर अपनी डिटेल्स फील
करेंगे एंड वफाई करके ओटीपी से आप यहां पे
इनरोल कर सकते हैं इनरोल करने के बाद आप
हमारे इस कोर्स को वेब पे भी यहां लॉगइन
करके एक्सेस कर सकते हैं और हमारी डिफ
एडमी ए एप पे भी लॉग इन करके एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं या तो इस कोर्स को आप डेनिक्स
academy-raviryala वो हमारे
whatsapp2 प्रैक्टिकल की जो कि एक अपने आप
में एक फ्री बट विद क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग
स्टार्ट हो रही है 10th नवंबर से पहली
क्लास आपकी 7 पीएम पे होने वाली है सो आई
होप आप सब बहुत ज्यादा एक्साइटेड होंगे इस
पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग के लिए एंड इस
ट्रेनिंग को कंडक्ट करेंगे आपके सचिन सर
जिन्होंने ऑलरेडी आपकी पूरी ओसन की
क्लासेस ले रखी हैं काली लिनिस की क्लासेस
ले रखी हैं बैच पढ़ा रखा है बहुत सारी
एंड्र पन टेस्टिंग की क्लासेस लाइव
ट्रेनिंग वो लेते हैं तो आप सबको बहुत डीप
लेवल की नॉलेज मिलने वाली है इस ट्रेनिंग
के थ्रू सो आई होप गाइज सिलेबस आपने पूरी
अच्छे से देख ली है आपको पूरी सिलेबस जो
है आपको समझ में आ गई होगी कि हम
क्या-क्या चीजें कवर करने वाले हैं जैसा
कि मैंने बोला कि सिलेबस सिर्फ इतना ही
नहीं है यह तो ऑटोमेटिक बहुत ह्यूज सिलेबस
है अपने आप में बट इसमें और चीजें ऐड अप
हम कर सकते हैं फ्यूचर में एंड आपको और भी
चीजें मिल सकती हैं सिलेबस के अंदर में तो
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सिलेबस है काफी चीजें
हमने कवर करी है और चीजें हम ऐड भी इसमें
करेंगे मेरी बस आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि
आप दो चीजों को हमेशा ध्यान में रखें पहला
आपको वहीं मिलेंगी अगर आप वहां पे नहीं
फॉलो अप करेंगे अगर आपको कोई अपडेट मिस
होता है तो उसकी जिम्मेदारी हम पे नहीं
होगी दूसरा कि आप इस सीरीज को लाइव आके इस
सीरीज को फॉलो करें शुरू से फॉलो करें इस
सीरीज में जो भी सिखाया जाए उसको सीखें
नोट्स के अपना खुद का नोट्स क्रिएट करें
इसका एक पर्टिकुलर नोट्स क्रिएट करके आप
अपने रिवीजन के लिए आगे के लिए रखें एंड
इस सीरीज को पूरे पैशन के साथ फॉलो करें
यकीन मानो अगर आप इस सीरीज को फॉलो करते
हो बग बाउंट सीरीज को फॉलो करते हो आपको
कहीं जाने की जरूरत नहीं है लिटरली बता
रहा हूं य लर्न अ लॉट ऑफ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स तो
हमें बस लर्निंग एंड नॉलेज से मतलब है
बाकी चीजें आप अपना हैंडल कर लो आपको
लर्निंग एंड नॉलेज जो है वो बिल्कुल फ्री
में क्वालिटी के साथ मिलने वाली है दैट्ची
बोलना चाहूंगा अगर आपको हमारा काम पसंद आ
रहा है आपको हमारी ये सीरीज आपको ये जो
ट्रेनिंग अच्छी अच्छी लगती है सीखने को
कुछ मिलता है तो आप हमें सपोर्ट कर सकते
हैं बस वीडियोस को शेयर करके अपने दोस्तों
के बीच अपनी कम्युनिटी में अपने सोशल
मीडिया हैंडल्स पे एंड लोगों को बता के
अवेयर करके कि ऐसी चीज यहां डिफन एडमी
इतना काफी है हमारे लिए फिलहाल इस वीडियो
के लिए इतना ही मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट वीडियो
में तब तक के लिए नमस्ते